i've been thinking about online
universities
well that's easy lectures and tests
that's what universities do it's like
no
that might be
maybe that's five percent of what
universities do five percent yeah i
would say so
here
well here's a bunch of things
universities do
they confer an identity upon you
who are you i'm a student
okay respectable
so for a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars let's say it's more than that
sometimes and less than that you now
have an identity for four years that
your culture respects and that means you
have a container within which you can
have intellectual freedom while you're
deciding what you want to do with the
rest of your life instead of torturing
yourself about how useless you are
because you don't have a productive job
yet so that's a big deal god only knows
what that's worth but not nothing
well
how about finding a mate
so there's evidence now coming out i
don't know how reliable it is you know
that it's about
two women for every man in many
academic institutions now and that
proclivity towards female dominance
seems to be increasing however it
appears that once the men dropped to one
third of the population the women
stopped going
well
you think why is that well why the hell
do you think it is you go out of your
little town you know you want to find a
new peer group and you're young it's one
of the things you want to do is find a
mate so part of the reason you go to a
good university is because
the sorting has already taken place it's
like well you know this person's got a
high school diploma and they're they're
clued in enough to pursue a college
filtering system yeah so that's a huge
deal and then universities also act as a
filtering system for businesses because
they use the sat as a entrance
requirement so if you hire someone as a
graduate from a high-end university you
knew that they had a high iq because the
s.a.t is an iq test and god only knows
what that's worth and then
you shed your peer group
your old peer group and you establish a
new one maybe when you're a bit wiser
and that's a i mean
one of the major
elements of my college education
was
the transformation of my peer group that
was huge and then there's personal
relationships between you and the
professors if you're lucky enough to
establish them that's a big deal because
then you get to interact with someone
who's
an embodiment of the academic tradition
and see how they act that's different
than listening to what they say in a
lecture
and then there's the social surround the
joint meals this is they make a big deal
of this at cambridge and oxford because
the students eat together in their
colleges and god only knows how
important that is
and then
there's the part of being an embodied
actor in that academic tradition and
learning to speak and write and
so that's just a handful of things
universities do and that's not lectures
and tests online
and to reduce it to that might destroy
it completely could easily be and it's
the same with our political institutions
they depend on these
real world
substructures that like like engagement
in civic society we have no idea how
important that is and the fact that
that's starting to deteriorate in
washington could be fatal you know you
know what i would be curious about you
know how in america the one school
university that was popping 20 years ago
and
everybody said oh yeah i can get my mba
on online it was what phoenix university
phoenix university right
and i recruited a few of their sales
guys and they're legit sales guys
because they they're selling is what
they're selling
um
i saw their sales training was great but
one of the things i'd be curious about
is
how much do they get from boosters like
kids graduate from phoenix university
and they got the degree online like i
wonder oh my gosh i'm so loyal to the
school i got to give these guys 10 grand
you know i want to contribute because
this university changed my life
did it though so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you